The Joe Rogan experience.
Right.
And then who did Doonesbury?
That's like the political one,
right?
Is that his name?
Maybe?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Who the fuck was Zit Trudeau?
What's his first name?
Gary Trudeau.
Isn't that,
what's the name?
The Guy who runs Canada.
Justin.
That guy?
Yeah.
I never got to and Sperry.
I never like,
it was like too clever.
I was just like,
okay.
They're like,
I guess they're taken down Ronald Reagan or something,
but I don't know what the fuck they're talking about.
Doonesbury's weird too because they basically,
they pigeonholed hunter s Thompson and turned him into this.
They had a character that they were doing.
I think he wound up suing them.
Yeah.
There's this character is basically the exact same guy,
just slightly different and he was always like shooting off guns and doing a
bunch of crazy shit.
I forget his name.
I forget the name of the guy.
They gave him a different name,
like uncle something or another.
Yeah,
but that was there.
I mean that was Garry Trudeau's take on hunter s Thompson and it wound up
driving hunters Thompson nuts.
Is this still real?
He's still doing like he's doing Trump this.
That's 2017.
Wow.
Yeah.
But he,
um,
so he created this character that was basically the most exaggerated versions of
hunter s Thompson one hunters Thompson was fucking around and it sort of defined
who hunter s Thompson was too.
A lot of people because instead of being this brilliant journalist who,
you know,
those great writer,
he also became this kind of like guy just shoots guns and Zoe's drunk and then
you fall into that trap.
I think comedians that have a persona like oftentimes fall,
like you know,
dice that's not,
you know,
his real name is Andrew Silverstein and the dice character was a part of his
act.
He's had a bunch of different things.
You do impressions.
We did Travolta impression.
Yeah.
Phenomenal.
Yeah,
phenomenal Travolta impression.
And then the dice man became like a part of his act and then he just decided
that's the best part.
So I'm just going to do dice all the time.
And then he decided,
you know what?
Fuck live in like a regular person.
It was going to be dice all the time.
So he became the guy in his act.
I mean,
that's who he is like most of the time.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Kinison Kennison and similar,
similar situation.
I'd never met Kinison Kinison I mean,
he died well before I got into stand up,
but I'd never met dice.
And I've always like sang his praises.
Like,
I think the day the laughter died is one of the greatest comedy albums of all
time.
Uh,
and uh,
and I've just never met him.
He's great.
Yeah.
I'll introduce you next time I see him at the store if you're there.
I've heard great stories.
He must like,
he must know who I am.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I wants to govern.
What if he wasn't what?
You'd be mad?
I wouldn't be mad.
I'd be surprised is because I've spoken him publicly that like if he was,
if he was wondering why he sold like a thousand copies of the day,
the laughter died after I like talked about it on a podcast.
Like he would hear that,
you know,
someone says something nice about you,
you find out.
Um,
but,
uh,
I was at governor's once and they were like all probably were like,
dice was here last weekend and he left one of his gloves,
you know,
the fingerless gloves.
And I was just like,
give it to me.
Like,
what do I have to do to take this glove home that I'd still have Alec where'd
around wet around.
Sometimes it's fun.
Do you read it and write jokes with it?
Oh,
well I'll walk around like just doing the,
doing a little,
there's a little o's but smoking cigarettes like blues.
Yeah.
But uh,
but yeah,
love,
love dies.
But those characters from guys get lumped into a character when you get locked
into that,
it can be very self defining,
you know?
Of course we're Kennison I think it was very self defined.
Oh,
big time.
I thought about that when I was like creating my persona.
It was like,
what's going to age?
Well,
you know,
like not like I think of a guy like Nick Swardson,
who's just like party all the time.
Like he's a college kid forever.
Right?
It's like,
how long can you do that for?
You know what I mean?
It's like still kind of asked to do it and it's still great,
but I'm like,
are you enjoying this?
You know,
like I want to be able to like kind of hold on to my dignity.
he's the best version of it.
Emo Phillips.
Yes.
That's the best example because it's like wow.
Like,
cause when he was a young sort of cute guy,
it was kind of strange to watch them do calm medical.
I plus when you're 60 though and you're doing that,
people are like,
hey man,
this is just weird.
Yeah.
Like bobcat talked about that like that bobcat had this moment where he stopped
being bobcat and people,
they came and how can we not do the scream?
He's like,
fuck you,
I'm not doing it.
I hate told me the best story ever.
He said,
he's in a,
he's at a comedy,
works in Denver doing a weekend and he's eating shit every show and every show
he's just bombing and everyone's going to do the voice,
do the voice.
And he was like,
no,
I'm not.
I don't do the voice anymore.
I'm not doing the voice late show Saturday.
Uh,
someone in the back yells,
we're from Aurora,
do the voice for us.
And he goes,
Oh,
you're from Aurora.
At least you learn to sit in the back.
And he said,
and this is like a year after the shooting of the movie there.
Yes.
A year after that.
And he said,
the entire audience,
the entire audience just pretended he didn't say it,
they didn't boo,
they didn't laugh.
They just acted like nothing had happened.
And he did the rest of the show when he said it made the whole weekend worth of
fun
just to say that,
just to say that.